THEIR STORE TO 21.
WALMART AND DICK'S SPORTING
GOODS ALREADY MADE THE
CHANGE IN REACTION TO THE
SCHOOL MASSACRE LAST MONTH.
LOOK AT ONE SCHOOL GOING
THROUGH EXTREME MEASURES TO
KEEP ITS STUDENTS AND
FACULTY SAFE.
HERE IS CORRESPONDENT DOUG
McKELWAY.
>> SCHOOL SHOOTERS ARE NOT
UNLIKE THE A SYMMETRICAL
FIGHTERS OF THE GUERRILLA
WAR.
THEY WIDESPREAD GRIEF IS OUT
OF PROPORTION TO THEIR
STRENGTH.
A FACT COMPLICATING THE
ONGOING DEBATES ABOUT HOW
INTRUSIVE AND HOW COSTLY
SCHOOL SECURITY SHOULD BE.
ONE COMPANY IS SPARING NO
EXPENSE.
[SCREAMS]
GET IN HERE, PLEASE, HURRY.
USING 400,000 OF OWN MONEY
VIRGINIA BASED TEST SCHOOL
IN INDIANA.
TEAMERS WEARING WIRELESS KEY
TO BEES CAN ACTIVATE A
SYSTEM OF ALERTS.
SMOKE CANISTERS AND OTHER
UNDISCLOSED COUNTER METHODS.
DOORS AND WINDOWS LOCATED
AND AREAS CONTAINED.
>> DONE AUTOMATICALLY.
THE SCHOOL IS WIRED DIRECTLY
SECURELY TO THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT 10 MILES AWAY.
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT CAN
MONITOR IN REALTIME.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY
INSIDE WITH A GUN THAT CAN
TAKE ON THE MAN THAT'S RIGHT
OUTSIDE THE DOOR THAT BY THE
WAY CAN SHOOT RIGHT THROUGH
THE STEEL DOORS?
>> THE PRESIDENT'S APPARENT
SKEPTICISM IS MATCHED BY
OTHER DOUBTS, $400,000 TO
FORTIFY A SCHOOL IS
PROHIBITIVE FOR MANY COST
STRAPPED DISTRICTS.
IN ADDITION SOME
PSYCHOLOGISTS BELIEVE BEEFED
UP SECURITY MIGHT ENCOURAGE
TROUBLED SHOOTERS.
>> INCREASE THE DRAMA AND
SPECTACLE.
IMAGINE DESIGNING A MOVIE
SET.
PLACE SWARMING ARMED GUARDS.
SOMEONE WITH FANTASY THAT
UPS THE CHALLENGE.
>> FLORIDA TAKING A
DIFFERENT ROUTE WITH POWER
TO APP. FORTIFY FLORIDA.
>> SOME KIDS ARE ON SNAPCHAT
AND INSTAGRAM.
THEY NEED A UNIFORM WAY TO
REPORT THAT ALSO WITH THE
CONDITION OF ANONYMITY.
>> SOME FEAR IT COULD SWAMP
AUTHORITIES WITH A PETTY
REPORTS.
KNOWN RISK WHY THE FAILURE
TO ACT ON THE MANY WARNINGS
ABOUT NIC LAZARUS CRUZ.
NIKOLAS CRUZ.
THREAT ASSESSMENT ON SECRET
SERVICE MODEL.
AT RISK INDIVIDUALS
WORKPLACE AND SCHOOL
VIOLENCE.
AS WELL AS ARSON, SABOTAGE
AND OTHER WARNING SIGNS.
>> OUR FOCUS IS ON HOW TO
TRAIN THE TEACHERS, FAMILY
MEMBERS, THE COMMUNITY, THE
BAR TENDERS, THE HAIRSTYLIST
ON HOW TO SPOT CONCERNED
BEHAVIOR AND HOW TO REPORT
IT.
>> PROFESSIONALS SAY THE
DATA WOULD BE WARN ONLY TO
WARN AND COUNSEL FAMILIES,
FRIENDS AND TEACHERS OF A